- [Instructor] We're told that Kyra works
on a team of 13 total people.
Her manager is randomly
selecting three members
from her team to represent
the company at a conference.
What is the probability
that Kyra is chosen
for the conference?
Pause this video and
see if you can have a go
at this before we work
through this together.
All right, now let's work
So we wanna figure out this probability.
And so one way to think about it is,
what are the number of
ways that Kyra can be
on a team or the number of possible teams,
teams with Kyra,
and then over the total
number of possible teams,
total number of possible teams.
And if this little hint
gets you even more inspired.
If you weren't able to
do it the first time,
I encourage you to try to pause it again
and then work through it.
All right, now I will
continue to continue.
So first let me do the denominator here.
What are the total
possible number of teams?
Some of y'all might've found
that a little bit easier to figure out.
Well, we know that we're
choosing from 13 people
and we're picking three of them
and we don't care about order.
It's not like we're saying
someone's gonna be president
of the team,
someone's gonna be vice-president
and someone's gonna be treasurer.
We just say there are
three people in the team.
And so this is a
situation where out of 13,
we are choosing three people.
Now, what are the total number of teams,
possible teams that could have Kyra in it?
Well, one way to think
about it is if we know
that Kyra is on a team,
then the possibilities are
who's gonna be the other
two people on the team,
and who are the possible candidates
for the other two people?
Well, if Kyra is already on the team
then there's a possible
12 people to pick from.
So there's 12 people to choose from
for those other two slots.
And so we're gonna choose two.
And once again, we don't care
about the order with which
we are choosing them.
So once again, it is
gonna be a combination.
And then we can just go ahead
and calculate each of
these combinations here.
What is 12 choose two?
Well, there's 12 possible people
for that first nine Kyra's seat.
And then there would be 11 people there
for that other non Kyra's spot.
And of course it's a combination.
We don't care what order we picked it in.
And so there are two ways
to get these two people.
We could say two factorial
but that's just the same
thing as two or two times one.
And then the denominator here.
For that first spot, there's
13 people to pick from ,
then in that second spot, there are 12.
Then in that third spot, there are 11.
And then once again, we
don't care about order,
three factorial ways to
arrange three people.
So I could write three times two,
and for kicks I could
write one right over here,
and then we can, let's go down here.
This is gonna be equal to my numerator
over here is gonna be six times 11.
And then my denominator is
going to be 12 divided by six
right over here is two.
So it's gonna be 13 times 11 times two.
Just to be clear, I divided
both the denominator
and this numerator over here
by six to get two right over there.
Now this cancels with that.
And then if we divide the
numerator and denominator by two,
this is gonna be three here.
This is gonna be one.
And so we are left with a probability
of 3/13 that Kyra is
chosen for the conference.